[Music]
[Music]
on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good evening i'm pierce morgan
uncensored tonight tennis legend boris
becker is behind bars his ex-wife joins
me exclusively for her first interview
since the shock sentence
and chess grand master turned putin
blaster the genius gary kasparov will be
live with me too but first my brain dump
it's a stunning seismic bombshell that
sends shockwaves across america and
indeed the rest of the world an
unprecedented leak from the u.s supreme
court shows that america's most powerful
judges are about to overturn roe versus
wade that's the landmark law which has
effectively legalized abortion in the
united states for the past 50 years
it's easy to forget when you live in a
country where abortion is legal and a
long accepted part of society that in
america this remains a highly charged
emotional debate that divides people
like almost nothing else protesters from
both sides immediately descended on the
court will not go back
we will not go back
if roe versus wade is over overturned
then individual states in america will
be free to set the rules and almost half
of those states are expected to move
swiftly to ban abortion if they can
already abortion laws in the united
states are a complete mess pro-life
states have for years made it as
difficult as possible to get an abortion
without themselves breaking the law a
woman who chooses to have an abortion in
missouri for example a state with a
population of six million people only
has one clinic to go to she'll have to
wait 72 hours before signing consent and
having the procedure the doctor is then
compelled by law to warn her that life
begins at conception but literally just
a few miles away in illinois in the
neighboring state the same woman can
choose from dozens of clinics and have
the procedure done on the same day so
you end up with this wretched confusing
patchwork of rules and so-called
abortion refugees traveling across state
lines at least those women who can
afford to do that
undoing roe versus way will most
definitely directly harm the poorest
women in u.s society who want an
abortion now i'm not an american so i
have no vote or say over what laws
americans have but i'm entitled to my
opinion and i believe women should be
free to choose what they do with their
bodies just as we men are more
importantly the majority of americans
agree with me and support roe versus
wade almost two-thirds of them in fact
just 27
say it should be scrapped
i'm pro-voice on pro-choice it seems to
me a dangerous moment for american
democracy when the supreme court goes
against the will of the majority of his
people on a matter of such personal
freedom
[Music]
well it's that million dollar question
again isn't it the treacherous puzzler
that's frazzling even the world's
biggest brains what is it is it what's
dark matter no not that one how big is
the universe
nope
when did life start
not even that one it's this
what is a woman
yes really
scottish nationalist leader nicholas
sturgeon has led his politician to be
tied in not to petrify panic by this
completely innocuous question asked by
the times to define a woman she said
i'm not going to i'm just not going to
get into this debate at a level that's
simplified and has lurid headlines trans
people are amongst possibly the most
stigmatized and discriminated against
minorities in our society
they have to say nicola
it's not a debate
it's literally a word that's a very
simple meaning
so there's nothing to do with trans
rights it's entirely possible to support
equal rights for trans people as i do
and answer this simple question with a
simple answer
just check any dictionary in the world
and you'll find that a woman is defined
as an adult human female that's it
that's the answer
and when you don't answer it like that
you do women and women's rights such a
massive disservice on a day when
american women are on the verge of
losing the right to decide what to
legally do with their bodies that
definition has never been more vital or
important
it's now 15 years since british toddler
madeleine mccann was snatched from her
bedroom during a family holiday in
portugal as their parents had dinner 50
yards away with friends madeleine's body
has never been found she may still be
alive nobody knows no one's been charged
her disappearance very few child
abduction stories grip the world quite
like this one it made global headlines
amid a desperate international search to
find her and to this day she's regularly
plastered across the front pages with
even the smallest of updates from police
inquiries
at the center of all this are her
devastated parents kate and jerry mccann
now i've interviewed them several times
i've always been struck by both the
terrible grief they feel for what
happened to the little girl and the
inevitable regret that their actions may
have contributed to her disappearance
your intelligent people
and you were certainly good parents
there's no one's questioning that from
all accounts we've all heard it's just
when you have people coming in and off a
street like that and it's not your home
and it's not really secure
again i mean i think it is back to the
safety issue we did not perceive an
element of threat and
child abduction is so rare why would you
have ever have thought that someone was
going to get into an apartment and steal
your child it just didn't enter their
head if it had
it wouldn't have happened and answer all
these questions day in day out why how
why and i can only you know say to
myself okay you felt really safe and i
know how much i love my children and
there's no way i'd have taken a risk
they don't need anyone to tell them they
shouldn't have left madeline alone with
her young siblings that night however
safe it may have seemed in the resort
they have to live with that decision
every day and they must eat away at
their souls but there's not a parent
alive who hasn't lost sight of a child
for a few moments or longer and felt
that sickening dread that the mccanns
have now had for 15 years it happened to
me once i lost one of my sons for 30
minutes near a running creek i'll never
forget the desperate despair that swept
over me all the unbridled joy when he
was found safe
the mccanns only have the despair
and to compound their misery vile trolls
bombard them with abuse every time
madeleine's name gets mentioned in the
media again even falsely and
disgracefully accusing them of being
involved in her death
to pour such vicious fuel on the endless
torment is the most disgusting form of
human callousness on this 15th
anniversary of her disappearance i pray
that one day the mccanns get the closure
about madeline that they crave
who knows maybe she's still alive god
that would be an amazing thing
but until then if you have nothing
compassionate to say about the mccanns
just shut up
as war rages in europe a deadly pandemic
continues to wreak havoc and ruinous
inflation these families living in fear
of being able to pay their next bill
well what better time for an elitist
ball and a pouting procession of our
most pampered prima donna celebrities
the annual met gala in new york last
night featured a gilded glamour dress
code apparently paying homage with no
sense of irony to america's era of
economic ascent this is lines for food
banks are through the roof you couldn't
make it up this might just have been the
most tone-deaf self-indulgent
narcissistic orgy of vain glorious
nonsense in recent celebrity history
stars protecting garish and in many
cases absolutely hideous gowns costing
tens of thousands of dollars parading
the red carpet apparently utterly
oblivious to the suffering going on in
the world outside them the main gala
used to be about the biggest and most
talented stars of entertainment beyonce
lady gaga rihanna strutting down that
carpet this year was a who's who of who
cares let's take a look at some of them
here's emily radachowski
the model
only shocking because the first time
i've seen her in clothes for about three
years
brooklyn beckham what's he doing there
his only claim to fame is his dad used
to kick a football around
hillary clinton she was described by
variety magazine as lucky regal regal
the only regal thing about what she was
wearing is it closely resembles the
curtains i saw at buckingham palace when
i went to meet the queen
as for kylie jenner apparently eight
people had to get her into this meringue
wedding dress and why was she wearing a
wedding dress
but the single most irritating moment of
the night came from well appropriately
the single most irritating person
kylie's big sister billionaire irritant
kim kardashian who turned up wearing
marilyn monroe's iconic nude-colored
happy birthday mr president dress the
one that marilyn wore when she sang to
jfk it has 6 000 hand-sewn crystals
woven into it and was sold a few years
ago for five million dollars at auction
kim might as well have pulled a maria
antoinette when she was at it had the
words let them eat cake etched into her
surgically enhanced backside miss
kardashian said she had to lose 16
pounds in three weeks to squeeze into
the dress and she is forever grateful
for the moment
i'm also forever grateful that i wasn't
there to risk my spleen spontaneously
erupting over this disgusting
desecration of one of the most famous
and classiest items of clothing in
hollywood history paul marilyn must be
turning in her grave and speaking of
greys on a more serious point what a
slap in the face this all was to those
who've lost loved ones to covet bombs
and poverty this year
well first tonight does a woman have the
right to choose what she does with her
body the answer might seem obvious to
many of you but tonight in america
there's a dire direct and dramatic
threat to that right an incredible or
frankly scandalously given draft ruling
suggests the supreme court will overturn
its 1973 decision that legalized
abortion nationwide that judgment was of
course roe versus wade now abortion
splits america often savagely along
partisan lines president biden is
unequivocal in his defense of rome he
said a woman's right to choose was
fundamental and roe has been the law of
the land for almost 50 years and would
not be overturned
well i'm joined now my conservative
radio host ben ferguson the socialist
author grace blakey welcome to both of
you ben ferguson i've got to say here in
the uk
this has been me met with complete
horror uh but i'm very aware i've spent
a lot of time working living in america
that the country is very divided about
this issue of abortion and for everyone
who is screaming this is appalling today
there are many uh republicans in middle
america who will be cheering from the
rooftops what's your view
uh look number one i think this is a
victory for protecting life for the
unborn we talk about protecting children
all the time you just had a story about
a child that went missing and how
horrific it is that child has been
missing yet we have 80 plus million
children that are aborted every year so
for me this is about protecting the
rights of the unborn i think that's a
good thing second of all no one should
be horrified in the uk or anywhere in
the world that this ruling came down
because abortion if they're terrified
that it's illegal that's not accurate
this is sending it back to the states
and the states have a right to decide
what their laws are the same way that
states in america have the right on gun
laws and look democrats have put
themselves in a toughest position right
now one because they can't even define
what a woman is anymore so you can't say
it's a woman's right to choose anymore
and two they the whole my body my choice
well they've also thrown that out the
window because they want to mandate
vaccines in america so the idea now is
well let's leak it from the supreme
court
let's have chaos at the court let's try
to shame people into doing what we
demand they do because we can't define a
woman and we can't say anymore my body
my choice when we demanded vaccines okay
they're in a bad spot as they should be
all right let me bring in grace are you
currently identifying as a woman before
we start yes i am okay good well as a
identifiable woman
uh what's your response to ben ferguson
my response to this is that america does
not want this the polls are clear this
is an assault on american democracy by a
highly organized group of religious
extremists who are seeking to force
women to have births and who want to
basically control use the power of the
american state to control women's bodies
this is a complete and utter violation
of basic human rights rights that the
american constitution that you hold so
dear was created to defend and not even
mentioning the separation between church
and state that this clearly goes against
because this is all about this tightly
organized sect basically within america
that wants to criminalize homosexuality
control women's bodies and basically
take your country
the 18th 19th century all right ben
ferguson you're from the 18th century
for the remain
yeah for the remainder of this interview
appears i identify as a woman because
apparently now you can do that so as a
woman now i want to make it clear she
has no idea what she's talking about
about the american laws the laws state
and she's completely wrong that you
don't rule at the supreme court based on
public opinion
you you rule on law
judging the thing the constitution
american as well so
let me finish let me finish you never
rule on the constitution based on public
opinion
let me ask you let me ask you this
question you and i have debated for
example gun rights many times over the
years you've always made it clear to me
there's no point bringing in new gun
laws because people will still be able
to get guns i would put it to you what's
the difference ideologically if you try
and stop people having abortions legally
they'll go and find them it'll just be
more difficult and actually the people
that will suffer most will be those who
can't afford to go to other states where
it's legal so you have a country which
will be split but the people suffering
most in terms of choice will be those
who can least afford to take other
options
again you're going back to the the
problem here which is it's a public
opinion is now what you're demanding the
supreme court decide on instead of what
the law actually says you look at guns
every single state has different gun
laws and no one is freaking out over
that
let me finish extreme gun laws the
reality is
democrats have gotten themselves in a
corner because they refuse to admit what
a woman is they refuse to admit that
again that you do have rights or don't
have rights of your own body they
screwed this up and so what the supreme
court is doing and what states like
mississippi when they challenge us
of course they did you can't even define
women
this has been a concerted campaign that
has existed in america again for many
many decades
victory
for religious extremism of the kind that
if it was taking place anywhere else in
the world would be rightly attacked by
the allegedly civilized liberal
democracies
to control a woman's body
okay for for the remainder of this
interview identify as as atheists okay
so therefore we fix that
problem doesn't care about any religion
wait let me finish as somebody that has
no religion right now i've just
identified as that this has nothing to
do with religion and again if you looked
at american laws which you clearly know
nothing about the supreme court is not
making a decision on religion this is
your religious bigotry towards people of
religion and bigotry doesn't believe in
god
just in the same way that many muslims
what is your personal opinion of
abortion
uh personally i believe that abortion is
wrong i believe that you protect the
life of the unborn child at the time of
conception as a father of three i
believe that as soon as they were
consumed that is a child and that child
should be protected and not aborted do
you have a doctor i don't know i don't
know your family but do you have a
daughter
i have three sons two that are twins
from in vitro so i know a lot about
conception and when it starts all of my
children
the question i was gonna ask you had you
said that one of your kids was a
daughter i just wonder what your view
would have been about the perennial
questions identifying all of them as
daughters right now so let's go there
right now
they're all daughters so let's have them
identify as daughters how would you feel
if you had a daughter who was
impregnated by a rapist for example or
through incest
would you still say that she was not
entitled to have an abortion
is a great question many of the states
that are saying that they will go with
whatever the decision is on roe v wade
have said unless it's life of the mother
rape or incest they will allow abortion
in those states including many of the
conservative states that you mentioned
earlier if it is personally
my child and they came to me and they
said i was raped and i am pregnant i
still believe that that is a child a
authentic human being at the time of
conception and i do believe that you can
give that child up for adoption if you
do not want to raise that child but it's
still a child and that child's life just
deserves to be defended it does not
denying people health care why are they
allowing people to go around murdering
each other this has nothing to do with
the conversation we're not denying
health care oh full
see this is when you know you've lost
the argument
denying people contraception basically
teaching a policy of abstinence telling
people it's wrong to have conservation
it's wrong to have sex so when that
inevitably does happen they have no
choice when they're very very young
other than just to have a child that
they don't want that is going to
completely destroy the final word
i would argue ben ferguson must have had
sex because he's got three kids so let's
just put that on the table right ben
but
yeah let me let me say this very clearly
if you're having to then go into health
care and arguing about health care to
defend your position on abortion you've
lost the argument
of america let me finish
let me finish
abortion is not illegal in america
with this ruling it is going to get your
way it will intuition again let me
finish let me finish i have a right to
an opinion so do you okay you both have
your right to opinion
supreme court has made it clear that
they have said it's a states rights
issue and that's what the issue is here
you don't understand the americans until
we see federal legislation imposed when
the republicans take back control um
that basically makes it illegal
everywhere okay your country is going
this way
it's a states rights issue we're going
to leave it there it's a lot this is the
kind of debate that's raging all over
america by the way so it's a good debate
to have i believe in uncensored debate
and passions are going to run very high
about this ben ferguson grace blakely
thank you both very much
thanks
well uncensored next up tennis legend
boris becky was sentenced to two and a
half years in prison i'll be joined
exclusively by his ex-wife and the
mother of his twelve-year-old boy and
that's lilly becker she'll be next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well sporting icon tennis legend boris
becker's behind bars after being
sentenced to two and a half years in
prison for hiding millions of dollars in
assets to avoid paying huge debts the
six-time grandstand winner was accused
of hiding his wimbledon trophies too and
his way bankrupt in 2017. well one woman
standing by him is his ex-wife lily the
divorced in 2018 but remain on good
terms and lily becker joins me now for
her first interview since the shocking
news of boris going to prison well good
evening
thank you it must be i mean for the rest
of us we're watching this iconic guy go
to prison it seems a terrible fall from
grace for him many people will think he
deserved it because of the scale of
money which he was involved in
trying to hide other people will think
it seems quite a severe sense it's but
for you
and his family and it's a big family and
he's had a complicated life in many ways
but it must be so personal for you
what's happened i think it's personal
for all of us like you said he said
we have a big family i call us the
original patchwork family in my um in
germany uh we all pulled together his
ex-wife to kids
um his current girlfriend lillian we all
the first thing we did was reach out to
each other yes and
um it's hard because it's public it's
everywhere it's hard because everybody
has an opinion about it rightly so
um and i'm here to to actually show
everybody that he has a bunch of really
strong women behind him and here to not
speak be for for him but to protect him
i mean i mean
it was well known that a while ago you
and his girlfriend lillian had a bit of
a spat you went on social media and had
a bit of a popular but has what's
happened brought you guys close in a
weird way that you both see a guy that
you've had great love for go to prison
absolutely and up until today i'm super
embarrassed and i'm we're going to meet
up pretty soon and i would love to
apologize to her face-to-face
she was the first one to uh reach out to
me i asked how i was doing how i was
holding up house armor days i said
absolutely i said thank you um we're
doing okay a okay as good as it can be
then i called by brother ex-wife and um
it was just a non-spoken thing it's like
right here we are let's get together and
let's protect this guy the humiliation
was already enough for him to have it
done
on air for three weeks long
sitting there not being able to to well
he can't defend himself but as if you
know boris you know you know that he has
pride
and uh to them be sentenced in everybody
immediately having something to say yeah
he deserves
we don't know what he deserves that but
humiliate your
humiliation that's his opinion when you
heard he was getting a two and a half
year prison center that's a long time
and this is the man who's the father of
yours your son amadeus he's 12 now what
was that moment like for you when you
heard the sentence i completely broke
down i couldn't hear i couldn't believe
what i was hearing because i was
convinced up until the judge made her
verdict that he was going to get off a
little bit lighter than i mean two and a
half years and i had to keep it together
and i did not know how i did it
i i kind of did it thank god my son i
was prepared i kept him out of school he
was upstairs does he don't know what's
happened i i i he does now he did i had
to break it down to him his kids will
tell him at school he'll see it on the
internet right i mean but there was the
thing i had kept we as a family
including boris lillian and the kids we
had
by
uh purposely not allowed him or spoke
about the trial or anything and then um
and i didn't have no chance but to break
my heart or actually his heart last
sunday and it's i don't wish this up on
anybody it was the hardest thing i had
to do with a 12 year old tell him his
dad was going to prison he did he just
couldn't grasp him still can't and it
breaks my heart but it just made me into
tiger mama because i feel now that
i think we've all been through enough as
a family there is a mother involved i'm
not here i'm not asking for sympathy i
don't want it nor would boris want that
i'm asking for empathy i'm asking for
everybody that had an opinion or wanted
to write about him
to please stop you saw boris just before
he got sentenced yeah
what was his state of mind about this
does he feel the judge did criticize him
for not showing any humility or
accepting he'd done much wrong
do you think as the time came nearer
that boris understood what he'd done and
it was wrong i think boys always knew
what was what was going to happen he
knew from the beginning this is it's
going to be a tough one it's going to be
worldwide but what do you do in a
situation like that you just go and be
mentally prepared and thank god
his mental health is so strong and he
was probably prepared for these moments
because uh life at boris is never boring
it's a headline of the headline and what
has happened to him now i think uh
please allow him to heal behind closed
doors and then do you know how he's
getting on in prison it must be a very
different experience liliana has told me
that he's okay he's fine i mean it's not
a five-star hotel is it like he can be
as good as he can be and what about
his sense of
pride you talked about earlier does he
feel a sense of shame about what's
happened wouldn't you i think everybody
is and that's why i feel that you know
he's embarrassed you know he's
humiliated he knows that everybody
always had so how is he going to pick
himself up from this
and
the best way he can stay trying to stay
mentally strong focused because it's
just an obstacle in the vote it takes a
pretty extraordinary guy he is
extraordinary well i was going to say i
know boris socially and i've always
liked him he's a he's a great character
and he was a wonderful sportsman i
remember when he won wimbledon he was
one of the best i mean amazing he's also
always had a magnetic appeal to women
still and here you are a beautiful woman
talking as his ex-wife very lovingly
about him lily and his girlfriend very
beautiful talks lovingly about him his
first ex-wife talks lovingly about him
you're all coming together
what is it about boris becky that has
that draw to women like you well that's
exactly it it's either you have it or
you don't he has a great charisma he is
a fantastic father a funny guy honest
and you either have that swag or not and
he is if you've met him you know how
charismatic he is you know when you sit
down and he tells a story you are just
glued to him he's got this blue eyes and
it's just a charm and this is how he's
won lots of fans how will he deal now
lily do you think with the fact he's now
a convicted criminal because he is a man
of pride and when he comes out of prison
it may be in a year a year and a half
whatever it may be he will come out as a
convicted criminal his life will never
be the same again it says who
well he is a convicted creator he is a
convicted criminal who says his life
will never be the same again for if the
people that are standing by him and
which is a lot i think don't we all of a
comeback kid he did yes and i'm going to
get
he has
well he's been committed for a crime
well he's going to do a good time for
those who don't those who haven't
followed it he was sentenced to two and
a half years for hiding 3.1 million
dollars in assets to avoid paying debt
so he got into heavy debt and he tried
to hide money which should have been
used to pay it off that was his crime do
you think that the sentence was
justified no i think it's way too harsh
absolutely i think it's way too harsh
should it be a punishment absolutely
um
i think personally obviously i'm biased
i'm i'm you know part of the
baccalaureate my last name is becca but
i think two and a half in in in
it's heart it's very harsh
but we knew from the beginning that this
judge he was not going to take no uh are
you hoping to take amadeus to see his
father
he is dying to see his father i have
just be
i have just told a 12 year old
that his father is in jail and the
saddest part about it was that i
couldn't break it down because these
kids are now going on youtube they are
going on the internet internet is crew
but he also has a
loving support system around him and um
he's curious
um and i've told him we all make
mistakes you pop i didn't listen to the
law and he's on the naughty step a
little bigger one and was the last thing
you said to boris before when he when he
last saw you i honestly i wrote him and
um i said to him
um see you next weekend if you want if
you want to see a uh or be good
he gave me this and i sent him a heart
and that was it
and you haven't spoken to him since he
went inside no
do you have to go in yourself
uh if if he would want to yes i mean
absolutely
with my son hundred percent i think i
need to be holding my hand with him and
of course i'm seeing him dying to see
him
lily i'm very sorry for what's happened
to you and to amadeus it's very tough
for a little boy to see his dad go to
prison i've got a lot of time for boris
i think what he did was wrong and i
don't try and justify that in any way
nobody is i don't think anybody is but i
hope he's okay
during his time in prison i hope he
comes out learning his lessons and that
we can get to see him again and uh the
fact that you stand by him as his
ex-wife says a lot about his character
yeah so thank you for coming in thank
you for having us appreciate it
well i'm sensing the next outspoken
putin's critic gary kasparov and why he
thinks ukraine is just putin's first
stop that's coming next
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
well you may have noticed i've still got
lily becker with me and there's a reason
for that because when the interview
ended she suddenly told me actually
we're not divorced i'm still married to
boris
and we have this extraordinary
conversation i said well why don't you
just stay here for a little bit and
we'll just resolve this once and for all
so everyone keeps reporting that you're
divorced you're still his wife you're
you're not divorced very much still has
a strange life as that may be but
we're still very much married they've
been since we
met our separate ways did you want to
get divorced
um oh yes
why did you ask me that i think it's
said you're the most intense lover he's
ever had in his life uh it was from the
beginning intenses it wasn't a complete
true
love story there is no introduction
about it and everybody that knows us
knows this you don't want to divorce him
do you
um that's it
it's not that i don't want to get a
divorce i think we should handle our
business at the right time this is not
the right time this is everybody's
involved we will do with house right now
you're still his wife and you still love
him of course i do
of course i do we all love him lillian
loves him barbara loves him amadeus
loves him but right now we need to be a
unity and i think this this let's get
divorced or not that's definitely on the
back burner let's get him started let's
get him right then we all get to as we
do right now and then we do it when it's
the right time okay well i wanted to
keep you here to set the record straight
so there we have it a world exclusive
boris brooke is not divorced from lily
they're still married
uh he's
talked about your crazy love i can see a
bit of crazy love coming back from you
to him so who the hell knows how this
all washes up but it's it's fascinating
and thank you for staying in and
clarifying that yeah of course i think
that's important too
good to see
onto more well maybe more serious
matters they're not obviously for the
becca family it's about as serious as
they can get but british prime minister
boris johnson has admitted the west was
too slow to act over russian aggression
in ukraine and said we cannot make the
same mistake again he became the first
world leader to address kiev's
parliament today echoing the words of
winston churchill the prime minister
urged the country to keep resisting
russian invaders
the so-called irresistible force of
putin's war machine has broken
on the immovable object
of ukrainian patriotism
and love
of country
this
is ukraine's finest hour
[Applause]
well joining me now is renowned putin
critic and former world chess champion
gary casper gary thank you so much for
joining me uh i really appreciate i'll
be following your twitter feed
uh absolutely assiduously now for the
last two months i think you've been
calling every part of this so accurately
what is your current reading
of what is happening in ukraine what do
you think putin wants to achieve and
what should we in the west be doing more
thank you for having me again uh
i
i think we should separate two things
one is humanitarian catastrophe
atrocities never ending atrocities
never-ending russian attacks against
civilians demolition of the country
that's all bad news and we all share
responsibility for inaction for so many
years ignoring the fact that for putin
attack on ukraine was not a matter of if
but when
on other side we could see that ukraine
army that successfully repelled putin's
attacks at the first stage of the war
and now is defending east is about to
become strong enough to counter-attack
and i think that with all the support
coming from the west from all
civilized nations
helping ukraine free harm and and also
helping them just to to feed people and
to support the army in any way possible
so uh with this support ukraine will
will win the war and will liberate the
entire country ukraine will be whole and
free crimea included and the way i see
that the liberation of crimea and
ukrainian flag raising sevastopol though
the beginning of liberation of of my
country russia from putin's fascism
has been asked for the free world
well i was going to say the putin has
been repeatedly saber rattling
threatening to to deploy russia's
nuclear arsenal do you think he's got
any intention of actually doing that
would he want to trigger world war three
in that sense with nuclear exchanges
with the west
i think he's bluffing
uh it's not just his own
own decision he needs enough uh support
uh among rank and piles of russian
military and i doubt very much that
there are many kamikaze
if
any kamikaze at all because they all
understand you know using even tactical
nuclear weapons will not uh terrorize
the west will not put western
governments in panic but it will it will
um invite an adequate response and i
think the whole idea of this nuclear
bluff was to
frighten
britain europe america and and prevent
them from supporting ukraine it didn't
work out and i think
all this ever rattling you hear now it's
a desperation it's panic and uh
listening to russian propaganda machine
i think they they can feel that the end
is near and and ukraine army is about to
start uh not just you know holding the
ground but liberating their country and
gary we all know from history that the
military defeat of dictatorship it's
it's always the end of of the dictator
well yes and i absolutely hope that what
you're reading of this is is correct and
turns out to be the case it would be
great to think that would happen
for you personally you're one of the
most famous people
in in russian modern history you were
the greatest chess bar i'm a big chess
fan
and you were by far the greatest most
successful chess player that there's
ever been really in the world
you had to leave russia a place that
reveres sports heroes like yourself
chess heroes do you yearn to go back in
a post-putin russia would you like to go
home
i think it's my duty because russia will
need a lot of work to do to uh return to
the family of civilized nations uh we
have to go through the process of um
exaggeration you know same as germany
did 80 years ago and and i think every
person like myself will be very helpful
i believe that i can do a lot to to help
rebuilding my country and making it part
of the global solution and no no more
permanent problem and when you see gary
the furore about wimbledon tennis at the
moment banning
russian and belarusian players from
competing at wimbledon do you agree with
the targeting of russian individuals in
sport and culture and so on or do you
think that that's a misstep
it's a tough question because as you
said you know i'm one of the most
decorated uh soviet russian athletes in
history
but at the same time i understand the
emotions not just ukrainians but
all
but of all all other uh
players by seeing russians taking part
in competitions as a compromise i can
offer one solution any russian player
who is invited and and wants to take
part in wimbledon or any other
competition whether it's chess or tennis
or elsewhere
must sign a declaration condemning
criminal putin regime and and this and
this uh uh horrible war that's the only
condition that uh that's that could open
doors for them if they're willing to do
it you know taking risk then i would i
would argue that they should be allowed
to play but not under the current
russian flag which is the flag that uh
that has been used to to um carry the
war um
in ukraine and the flag uh that's uh
that's being carried by the army are
responsible for
war crimes on industrial scale okay the
neutral flag flag of the international
organization or whatever i'm going to
leave it there gary uh fascinated to
talk to you i i do follow your tweets
very closely i think you've been calling
this uh superbly well throughout this
conflict and i hope that your reading of
it is correct and that ukraine
ultimately prevailed thank you very much
indeed i appreciate you joining the show
thank you and glory to ukraine thank you
absolutely
i'm talking of glory uh in ukraine there
have been some truly heartwarming
moments amid all the misery too a 23
year old nurse called oksana had been
out walking in the eastern city of
leicester changs ahead of her fiance
victor she turned to warn him of the
danger and a second later a mine
exploded underneath her she lost both
her legs and four fingers in the blast
but she survived and this week they got
married in the hospital where she's
being treated in la vie this is the
moment she shared her first dance with
her new husband in hospital
[Music]
[Applause]
congratulations to oxana and victor what
a wonderful end to what must have been
an absolutely appalling few weeks for
the couple
uncensored next against a backdrop of
war and inflation crisis and a pandemic
was the met gala most tone death
celebrity shambles of all time or the
daughter of legendary joan rivers
melissa rivers will be here with me next
to go over it all
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well let them eat kate that was the
clear message from the met gardener last
night as the real world deals with a
brutal war a deadly pandemic and saw in
inflation billionaire irritant kim
kardashian
led the ostentatious showing off in new
york uh as she turned up in marilyn
monroe's five million dollar happy
birthday mr president dress
um miss kardashian said that she cried
when she realized she didn't fit into
the dress yeah maybe cry about something
a bit more worthwhile in the world would
be my advice for her but i'm going to
bring in melissa rivers now
uh to discuss all this melissa hey great
to talk to you how are you hi pierce how
good how are you it's been a long time i
lost all your celebrity apprentice with
our old friend donald trump
yes yes i think we've actually seen each
other one or two more times since then
but i think that's probably the most
memorable
let's talk met gala here's my view of
this i just thought it all looks so
inappropriate to me a bunch of wealthy
celebrities turning up in ridiculous
outfits all costing tens of thousands of
dollars
led by kim kardashian in a 5 million
dollar marilyn dress which she shouldn't
have been allowed to wear all showing
off how rich and famous and loaded they
are and so on and privileged at a time
when we have a war a pandemic and
surging inflation tone death
by so i guess we know now how you feel
am i wrong
okay i don't think you're necessarily
wrong but let's just roll back for a sec
first of all the fashion industry was
decimated
during covid and it's not just about the
designers it's about the people that
make the dresses and make the fabric and
the mills and the people who build them
so there's a whole other part of the
industry that people don't see how can
they spend so much money melissa and yet
so many of them look so awful but
they're not paying for it it's all good
some of them turned i mean kylie jenner
turned up in this wedding dress and
baseball cap apparently had 80 people to
pack her into it i mean utterly
ridiculous
i i'm not saying they're all good but it
really is and i understand completely
what you're saying and this was a big
discussion around the bringing back of
the oscars and all these things
but it is a night that
yes there it's supposed to be incredibly
over the top
and the the kylie thing i did not
understand
one iota
maybe i'm too old to go was it all about
low remember melissa i mean when you've
got a bunch of kardashians emily
ratachowski finally keeping some clothes
on you've got one of the beckham kids
who's only famous because his dad kicked
a football it all looked very low rent
there was no beyonce no rihanna no lady
gaga just a bunch of reality stars and
footballer sons
well that's been a big debate
about a number of high-end magazines and
who they're using in the magazines as
well as people who are would never 10
years ago would have been invited and
there's a big debate within the fashion
industry of that's appropriate but if
you go back kind of to my original point
these are the people that get attention
and it's a night to promote fashion
which is a
you know multi-billion dollar industry
but here's my problem just trying to win
but that's just trying to get back on
its feet but then you get someone wait
like rizzo med
like rizzomed who i know people are like
oh i can't believe you wore that i
thought what he wore was brilliant
because he came out and said this is
representing the people the workers you
don't see
and i thought that was so smart
and so on but i would take you back to
what you just said well you said that a
lot of them are there because they get
attention and it seems to me that it
personifies the modern day celebrity
curse where people like the kardashians
the beckham's kids
emily radochansky all these people
they're not actually talented in their
own right they're just there because
they get attention
and celebrity used to be in the days of
marilyn monroe when she actually wore
that dress and sang to president kennedy
that was an amazing moment because she
was a proper movie star
these i this look traipsing up the
carpet last night they're not proper
stars they're just wanna be attention
seekers
but this is also a major
um discussion on a totally different
topic which i'm always happy to have
with you because i'm very much of two
minds about it
there's the business mind and then
there's sort of the hollywood history
of talent it's the talent mind and
there's the untalented one
if you do an episode on that you and i
could have a phenomenal conversation
about it and we can get super academic
and granular
so you and i would have a great time i
just don't think we can discuss the
kardashians and use the phrase super
super academic but we're gonna leave it
there uh melissa love me to talk to you
come back let's talk about celebrity
culture next time because i've got a lot
of strong views about it
anytime i'm there for you great to talk
to you all the very best
right well i knew they'd eventually come
for the ham sandwiches
[Music]
primary school children in australia are
being urged to ditch ham sandwiches
because of the danger posed by processed
foods is that where we've got to now
really
ham is the new devil of the school
lunchbox
compared to what i used to be forced to
eat at school this is luxury food up
there with caviar lobster now i've been
eating ham sandwiches my entire life
look at me i'm perfectly normal
we've got to stop wrapping our kids so
tightly in cotton wool how are we going
to prepare them for the real world when
even a humble ham sandwich is deemed a
clear and present danger to their lives
give me a sandwich tim quick
one person who's standing up to this
madness is top aussie brexit presenter
carl stovanovich
it's a story that has got the whole
country furious this morning it also has
butchers and pork producers shouting out
loud
hands off our ham
this country's gone to the pack
yes it has and the show of solidarity
carl to you in australia here is a ham
sandwich i'm going to eat it good night
keep it uncertain and eat ham
[Music]
biggest issue in britain right now
undoubtedly is cost of living it is
energy on all that goes with that
inflation look you know i don't want the
government to do very much step back
from most of our lives but you know
there's a point when you say actually
these guys are getting a grip somewhere
along the line you want
to believe that the system that is meant
to be running things the chancellor the
prime minister who are going to somehow
step in and make life just a little
easier for the average person
[Music]
talk tv news at nine
good evening i'm sarah suleiman the
prime minister has confirmed that the uk
is to send 300 million pounds of support
to ukraine in the next few weeks boris
johnson made the announcement as he
addressed the country's parliament where
he described ukraine's resistance to
invasion as its finest hour
elsewhere there are reports of an
explosion in lev near the polish border
the city's mayor says strikes have
damaged power stations cutting off
energy
johnny depp's lawyers have argued he
lost 33 million pounds in earnings after
his ex-wife amber heard wrote an article
in the washington post which he claims
defamed him depp's libel suit against ms
heard continues as she prepares to take
the stand tomorrow
well that's all for now we'll have more
after the talk
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you